de que villa perdió su hijo menor en la
guerra de siria la acompaña a la
oscuridad rahim murió luchando con las
fuerzas del gobierno fue el quinto de
sus once hijos en fallecer a causa de
los enfrentamientos santo perdí la vista
en mi ojo izquierdo debido al silencio y
a las lágrimas contenidas no pude ver
con él después de que rahim se fue
cuando rahim se fue la luz abandono mío
nada andoain la guerra le cambió la vida
por completo y más ahora visita las
tumbas de sus hijos en este cementerio
acompañada por sus nietos y dirige una
fábrica de confección de ropa donde
enseña ese oficio muchas mujeres sirias
para que puedan encontrar un sustento
económico
la guerra se llevó a nuestros corazones
nuestros hijos son nuestros corazones
son nuestras almas
son la sangre que corre por nuestros
corazones
mis hijos son mi pulso que puedo decirlo
el conflicto también le dio un giro a la
vida de aysa tuvo que desplazarse de
alepo a frame en el norte de siria un
territorio controlado por los rebeldes
vive en esta casa abandonada desde allí
recuerda a sus dos hijos
nos fuimos diciendo que íbamos a
regresar en 10 o 15 días
ha venido a learning que mis dos hijos
se quedaron allí en alepo
uno de ellos quedó a salvo mientras que
el otro murió
dos relatos particulares que narran en
singular la historia de más de 350 mil
vidas que se ha cobrado la guerra de
siria una que cumplió 11 años este mes y
que según naciones unidas ha dejado casi
14 millones de personas desplazadas
otras 14,6 necesitan ayuda humanitaria